peggy 18.
[Music]
don't worry it's okay
i'll always be with you
see the set
the day is ending
let that yawn out
there's no pretend
together you can help us reconnect
you can make america whole
america's finished sam if we don't all
come together again
humanity will not survive we don't need
a country
not anymore we do alone we have no
future
bridget you're the president of jack's
[ __ ]
it's all to safeguard the continued
independence of edge not city
they want the uca to leave and be who
are these [ __ ] again
homo demons militant separatist group
i've heard of them a bunch of terrorists
who go around towns killing people
and leaving craters right
nothing's off limits for them not even
engineering void outs
there are extremists like the demons
everywhere
plotting in the shadows
foreign
uh
rules
good thing it was raining even they know
better than the mess with bts
i can't spot bts just sense them
that's why we came prepared i'm bridge
baby huh
makes me feel like [ __ ] every time
oh you are plugging into the other side
it freaks me out too
[Applause]
[Applause]
hmm
i want you to go west and finish what
emily started
rebuilding america isn't going to get
rid of the bts
long as they're still around there's no
escaping it
but at least we'll have hope
[Music]
you see i've come to understand the
truth of the death stranding
oh it's so hard to form connections when
you can't shake hands
fortunately i've got a good connection
to the other side
[Music]
uh
covering the world in cable didn't bring
an end to warren's suffering
don't act surprised when it all comes
apart if you try to do it again
humans aren't made for living alone
they're supposed to come together
to help one another and if we
as a people can't do that if we can't
reconnect
that's what we need right now not to
stand apart but to come together
i'll show you the real thing soon i
promise
the whole wide world will be useful
explore
you'll be able to go wherever you want
even the moon
for the players